[Applause] what's up everyone I'm Anson Carter
I'm here in Melbourne Australia the 2023 Global
series I got the greatest job in the whole
entire world thanks to visit Victoria I'm
getting the VIP treatment let's go see some
sights and sounds let's go oh first stop at
11 team Hill should be there pretty soon I'll see
the way you gotta applying like this is something
you're gonna take away for the rest of your
life go talk to your kids or your family about
say can you believe I went to Australia it's all
because of hockey pretty well do what you thought
put it down right here we're here today that
is much easier than driving okay we're good
we're here for the Hillsville Sanctuary we're
about 60 minutes outside of Melbourne about
400 different species here so I already
see some koalas some kangaroos a lot of
uh Wildlife here now we're talking a little bit
of rain it's not gonna slow me down I probably
shouldn't wore White Shoes though baby emu
over here it's a cute little baby over there
fascinating the koala comes from our first
Nations people from their indigenous language
and it actually means no drink koalas don't
drink water koalas get all of their nutrition
including their liquid from the eucalyptus
leaves that they eat the eucalyptus leaves
are very low in energy so koalas actually
sleep up to 20 hours a day why kind of my
support getting ready to go to lunch some
wine tasting and stuff my belly I'm out
I'm hearing that little bit of
wine tasting is on the menu so
can't wait to try a little
Australian Cuisine see you inside
look at this view Vineyards for days so how
do you guys get the grapes now you guys do it
manually like they hand pick hand-picked
what variety of grapes are we looking at
as we're looking at chardonnay pinot noir
Shiraz Cabernet Sauvignon France so it's
been all helpful and useful information
if I believe everything you said just
now so let's go try and put it the test
let's do it Fergus let's go you thirsty
this is impressive look at all these barrels
smells pretty good and Pokey you'll be able
to turn those barrels over year on year
on year things like shiraz and Cabernet
and those sorts of things they'll stay in
barrel for like a year and a half let's go
a quick look at some chilling mate this is
this year's wine so it's filled on the 29th
of March this year this is just one barrel of
one particular parcel of one particular block
of Chardonnay well you know it's very Oaky
let it breathe a little bit hold on a second
mmm it's pretty tasty hide behind this
all done Pinot Noir 2023 from block 12 on
this Vineyard I was like I get into the head
black cherry yes I was gonna say that
a little black cherry so there's red
cherries I've got a sophisticated
palette so I know the difference
it's a good day on this play Paul this is amazing
thank you for the tour appreciate the tasting
thank you for your time cheers what a
perfect day helicopter ride hanging with
koalas wine tasting in the basement and now
I'm being blessed with this beautiful meal
thank you thank you thank you for the
VIP treatment visit Victoria and make
sure you tune in to the 2023 Global
series cheers [Music] foreign [Music]